what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the fall of X and we're
picking up with Captain America joining
the X-men with the Avengers Unity squad
for those of you guys who don't know
what that means quick little bit of an
introduction here in the aftermath of
Avengers vs X-Men when the two groups
fought each other in order to bridge the
gap between the two the unity Squad was
formed as a team that's composed of both
Avengers and X-Men this is a different
roster but a similar roster at the same
time so this one picks up with what's
called an orcus filtration Center and
this is the cool thing because orcas is
learning right like we mentioned in the
dark X-Men video and years past in
Marvel Comics whenever Humanity was
looking to enslave the mutant population
they would slap these metal inhibitor
collars around their necks that would
shut their powers down what orcas is
doing is they're actually giving them
injections directly into their
bloodstream now we can largely assume
these are like some kind of nanites that
suppress their powers but it's a pretty
interesting concept because seemingly
what that would mean is that with the
exception of a full-blown blood
transfusion or simply killing them and
bringing them back through Resurrection
assuming that's even possible these
mutants who are de-powered are never
going to get their powers back now we're
kind of guessing here but that seems to
be the case now the cool thing about
this is that while they're all being
told to move there's a woman with a
cloak who just stops and this guy
literally tells her right this orcus
agent tells her you have to keep going
she pulls out a sword and she helps him
finish with all his living blood goes
everywhere
only for us to find out it's psylocke
now here's the thing to know right if
you guys are not familiar with the X-Men
psylocke is dope psylocke is what I like
to refer to as a murder machine because
this girl is next level dangerous she's
like one of the deadliest women on the
face of the planet her ninja training
combined with her second abilities given
the whole history of psylocke which
we're not going to get into here it
makes her one of the deadliest people of
all time now we end up finding out it's
not just her she's actually joined by
Monet Saint Croix now here's the thing
about Monet she's got a ridiculously
complex history that is the definition
of overly complicated comics in the
1990s and Generation X all you really
need to know here is this girl has a
whole host of powers telepathy
invulnerability super strength super
speed she's not really listed as an
Omega Level mutant but let's just be
honest with ourselves if for no other
reason than just the sheer number of
powers that she has she might as well be
but between these two girls they can
take all comers they can annihilate
virtually anybody out there right
they're that deadly now one of the other
things that makes psylocke so deadly is
the fact that she was personally trained
by the hand for those guys you don't
know what that means the hand is the
deadliest ninja organization in the
world in Marvel Comics that's a group
that can get into a room kill you and
leave and the only way in and out is a
door that's locked that was never luck
it's it's crazy what these guys are
capable of right they come at you with
overwhelming Force but in the middle of
all of this psylocke is suddenly met by
Steve Rogers when she goes to slash and
the sword won't cut his shield because
it's Captain America shield nothing cuts
the shield and so initially she actually
goes to fight him for a second because
she believes that he's a protector of
the forces of orcas and she even goes so
far as to ask like let's make this a
fair fight where are the rest of the
Avengers and she's not jesting here
right psylocke's not just talking trash
sure the Avengers would take her down
but they would take her down like
eventually right like she would get her
licks in and she'd take out more than a
few of them before they finally took her
down for the counts like that girl's
wildly capable now of course Deadpool
joins in the midst of all of this
because what's an Avengers Unity Squad
without Deadpool on the team but the
thing is Captain America literally tells
her like I wanted to talk to you about
that right I want to talk to you about
the Avengers I'm reinstating the
Avengers Unity Squad now with both Monet
Saint Croix and psylock having telepathy
they read the mind of Captain America as
much as they can because one of the
things to know is that whenever you're
talking about like higher ranking
members of The Avengers usually they
have some kind of mental conditioning
that keeps telepaths from being able to
just wholesale read their mind so
Captain America does have a level of
telepathic immunity but they are able to
detect his thoughts enough to know that
he's telling the truth and one of the
things that psylocke says is look I
don't mind being a part of your little
boy scout team but understand I'm not
going to listen to lectures from you
about how like we shouldn't kill and
that kind of stuff their wholesale
slaughtering and annihilating the
entirety of the mutant population so if
you're okay with me helping people
finish with all their living right
unaliving these different members of
orcus then sure I'll join your team if
not I'm out now let's be honest with
ourselves Captain America would be a
fool to let psylocke go right she's just
that capable she's a piece you want on
your chess board and that's why he says
then avenge them right he doesn't shoot
here's what I'm saying no we don't kill
you know no no he's like no we'll kill
him if we have to because that's just
the way that it is it's one of the best
things about Captain America you don't
often see Steve Rogers saying yeah let's
just kill everybody kill them all you
don't usually see that all that often in
Marvel Comics but when you do see that
that's when you know things are popping
off secret Empire was a great example of
when that happened right Captain America
conquers the Marvel Universe it was nuts
but what ends up happening of course
Deadpool tells them like we basically
have all the explosives that are set
Quicksilver appears because he's part of
the team and they effectively bail out
of there and then blow the place to
pieces now Quicksilver was able to get
those who had not been injected with the
nanites as far away as possible right
literally whisking them away using a
super speed but the other part of this
is Rogue because that's the question
that a lot of you all have had ever
since we covered Avengers 25 and the
start of fall of X when Rogue showed up
whisked Xavier away and then he told her
you have to get out of here try to find
survivors try to do what ever you can to
overcome the power of orcas a lot of the
guys have been wondering where she been
at this is it she joined the unity Squad
and it makes perfect sense because she
was part of the original Unity Squad now
what she's doing is really more like
Recon work than anything else which is
flying up to Orcas bases and seeing how
close they can get before their early
surveillance system detects them which
she realizes it's about 200 yards right
so she ends up traveling back to Captain
America to report the information and
then you pick up with Captain krakowa
alongside the blob and wild child now
blob and wild child don't matter and
they never did but Captain kirkoa does
so Captain rakawa when he initially
appeared in Marvel Comics which he's a
very new creation it was just Cyclops
basically kind of like the mutant
population Zone Captain America type
character if you want to call him that
but with Cyclops being held captive by
really Dr Stacy's Sinister whatever and
his eyes being sewn shut we know it's
not him so someone else is masquerading
as Captain krakowa and we don't know who
it is but what he's doing is he's
actually infiltrating to the island of
krakowa in order to find mutants at
least a couple of mutants in particular
who are being held captive there that
will join his cause now one of the
things that we're told about Captain
krakowa is that this is a man of lies
that with the exception of very few
people most surviving mutants out there
still believe he's Cyclops because they
don't know that Cyclops was captured
there are some who know it's not him but
really he just kind of allows the ruse
to continue on because in reality it's
better that people believe he's someone
he's not and cheer on the idea of
Captain gracoa than to tell people the
truth and then they become disillusioned
in him but it's also him lying about
being detected by like the forces of the
Sentinels and so on and so forth now
what's also kind of wild about this is
when he actually gets to the island of
gracoa the islands cry because it's
witness and it really just kind of
watching the complete and total of what
what appears to be the extinction of the
mutant population but once captain KOA
gets to the center of the island down
into the pit he ends up coming across
Fenris also known as the Von strucker
twins right Andrea and Andreas now these
two are not like overly powerful but
they are cool right they're kind of like
Marvel's version of the Wonder Twins
from DC Comics they can fire like these
ridiculously powerful and super hot
plasma bursts but they have to be
holding hands while they do it but
Captain cocoa shows up here and with
them just kind of buying into the idea
that he Cyclops he doesn't really
dismiss he doesn't really say like I'm
not Cyclops he just says that name is
dead I'm captain grecoa now and forever
so he's just kind of like I mean maybe I
am maybe I'm not but I'm Patrick that's
all you need to worry about ultimately
Andreas is like is somebody gonna like
help me get up and the response of
Captain krakowa is kind of like I mean
we will but like I'm gonna take your
sister in the back we're gonna get to
know each other a little bit right like
they're gonna bang not really he doesn't
say that but it'd be amazing if he did
but what you end up doing here is you
switch over to what we had covered in
X-Men 25 when you had Captain America's
Unity Squad meeting with the X-Men right
this kind of it's one of those moments
that just ties into it if you didn't see
our story I'll provide you a link to the
followbacks playlist at the end of this
video so you can get caught up but again
it's just kind of meeting and talking
sharing information that's all that's
really happening here and it is kind of
cool to see that Captain America is one
of the guys working alongside the mutant
population in this way and even with the
Sentinels Captain America tells them
like Tony Stark is working on something
that can overcome the Sentinel
technology but it's his own Tech that's
been taken away from him and being used
to create anti-mutant Sentinels so how
does Tony Stark defeat his own
technology that's what he's trying to
figure out now of course Miss Marvel's
here and just like she's been doing for
the entirety of the fall of X event she
stands around and does nothing so
ultimately Quicksilver ends up grabbing
everybody and whisking them out of there
as fast as he can so that nobody can
catch up to them and then you finally
get this conflict where Captain America
who's been tracking down Captain cracola
this entire time comes head to head with
him now rumors abound about who this guy
is and the biggest theory that I've seen
that's circulating around here is that
it's Magneto right maybe his memories
are wiped or whatever it is but like
Magneto's back and it's not the first
time Marvel's done that right like
anybody who's been reading the X-Men
long enough especially back in the 90s
you remember Joseph it was a terrible
concept of Marvel Comics but they've
done it before so it's not like it's a
brand new thing but the cool thing here
is that you do get a fight between like
Monet and wild child and psylocke and
all these other forces and all that kind
of stuff it doesn't really matter the
cool thing here is the fight between
Captain America and Captain krakowa
because we didn't fully know what this
guy was capable of we don't know what
all he can do right when it was Cyclops
it was him just running around and doing
stuff we don't know what this guy's
abilities are this guy overpowers
Captain America and we get this like
amazing kind of monologue right like the
krakowan battle suit was designed to
amplify the strength of ordinary
non-combatants giving them an edge
during an extinction level event whoever
this new captain krakowa was he was much
stronger than any ordinary human and in
fact he taunts Steve Rogers right he
says tisk your attacks are so obvious
and predictable now allow me to break
you of that habit and he snaps Captain
America's arm on the spot this guy
overpowers Steve Rogers and that's no
small thing with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end if you
guys need to get caught up on fall of X
make sure you click this link to the
playlist and I will catch you all later
peace